if you decided to one day go on YouTube
looking for old Howard Stern Clips you'd
have a lot of edgy Politically Incorrect
content to choose from Stearns many
segments with an intellectually disabled
dwarf comedian named Beetlejuice for
example are not very hard to find
there's also a bunch of compilations of
people fighting on Stern's set in the
style of Jerry Springer usually over
money or adultery or whatever there's
enough degeneracy there to last you
weeks if for some reason you were
inclined to go and seek it and watch it
but there's some recurring Howard Stern
content that's not so easy to find
because by and large it's been scrubbed
from most major video sharing sites the
segments I'm talking about involve Stern
speaking about his sexual attraction to
Children specifically Mary Kate and
Ashley Olsen again and again for several
years several years Stern described the
Olsen twins as sexually attractive
quote they're so amazingly hot Stern
says in one of his segments referring to
the underage girls and in several cases
Stern brings up the girls unprompted
leading to um awkward moments with his
co-host
because it's not possible to truly
eliminate any content from the internet
you can still find this footage if you
know where to look a small handful of
anonymous accounts have defied corporate
sensors and uploaded some of Stern's
many disturbing comments about children
that he finds sexually attractive so
here's just one example where Stern
laments that the girls in his estimation
aren't as attractive uh now as they were
when they were 13 years old listen to
speak of them individually is when they
turn 18 who you want to bang first
it was weird I was reading this magazine
yeah Mary Kate or Ashley exactly well
actually Beth was reading a magazine she
goes hey did you see this and she I
forget what magazine it is but it's the
Olsen twins hugging each other in a
photo shoot and they go this is Howard
Stern's fantasy you're kidding what
magazine did this I don't know
I don't know it was some magazine and
you know what though I don't really want
to have sex with them anymore
I can't I don't know they got kind of
dwarfy looking which one of them looks
like a monkey
exactly it's it's like something went
wrong like they stopped growing or
something they're not as hot as you
thought they were going to be no yeah
and really looked for a while like when
they were 13 or 14 they were going to be
supermodels but then they got they stuck
right there they kind of yeah they kind
of like didn't grow or something it's
weird and I was counting down at their
18th birthday so we could have sex with
them but not everybody was up to that
like uh what's her face did Alyssa
Milano she lived up yeah she got hot
someone told me she's really hairy
though who Alyssa got a belly hair and
really yeah I like like picking up I
told you that I don't know she's a
guinea yeah how dare you
the bills and towards get that Hobbit
looking thing going you know right like
they they live in Middle Earth yeah they
come their money make them look yeah
okay so you see there not only did he
always talk about wanting to have sex
with underage girls but but uh as he
says it was in a magazine
presumably some sort of uh some sort of
a tabloid magazine it was a it was like
a running joke in the entire media
everyone in the media knew oh you know
that that old man Howard Stern wants to
have sex with his underage girls isn't
that so funny did everybody knew it
and just accepted it as some charming
Quirk of Howard Stearns
and there are many more Clips like that
that we could play some are even more
disturbing than the one you just heard
this is a grown man in his 40s at the
time repeatedly sexualizing children who
are barely teenagers
now many people have had their lives
destroyed have been reduced to groveling
apologies
for saying things they're not that are
not even a tenth as bad
that's what Stern says there and that
wasn't even a tenth as bad as other
things that Stern would frequently say
these clips were though nauseating and
creepy when he made them and they're
nauseating and creepy now there was
never a point in American history where
it was acceptable to sexualize children
like this but for years Howard Stern
continued doing just that right out in
the open
nobody stopped him
he didn't seem ashamed of it at all he
tracked the Olsen twins from puberty to
adulthood commenting on their sex appeal
as he perceived it
at every turn
well somewhere along the line Howard
Stern and his team decided that he had
to stop talking about the Olsen twins
and and more than that someone decided
that all of Stern's past comments about
the Olsen twins needed to be purged from
the internet
all the other degenerate segments or
most of them could stay online but the
stuff where he lusts after young
children well well that had to go
and it was different from all the other
smut it was too damning and so they went
in and they tried to get rid of it
and with that evidence mostly expunged
from the internet Stern has embraced
pretty much every agenda item of the
Fortune 500 he's now officially a woke
Hall Monitor by his own admission
in fact this week Stern proudly
identified as woke listen
if woke means I can't get behind Trump
which is what I think it means or that I
support people who want to be
transgender or I'm for the vaccine
dude call me woke as you want
now as part of this new woke Persona
Stern attacked Lauren bobert for her
inappropriate behavior in that theater a
few days ago this is the guy who spent
the first three decades of his career
being a creepy degenerate sex fiend
and now he's playing the prude now he's
pretending to be scandalized
by the sort of behavior that that he he
would openly have on his show all the
time
he's become a pathetic old washed-up
school mom but he's now shielded by his
new woke identity he's immune from
accusations of hypocrisy just like he's
immune from accusations of being a dirty
old man attracted to children
it's a revealing transformation if only
because it shows how little daylight
there is between low-call monitors and
depraved pedophilic scumbags
depraved pedophilic scumbags and will
call monitors they're not two
destinations on opposite ends of the
spectrum
like he went from one
to the other at no point did he kind of
make a pit stop and and try out being a
decent normal person you never try that
out
that's because it's not a long journey
to get from one to the other they're in
the same neighborhood and there's a lot
of overlap
and they know it Howard Stern knows it
which is why he's sensitive about all
those clips of him salivating over 13
year old girls there are other old clips
that are inconvenient for stern too of
course clips that are um especially
relevant after what just happened to
Alex Jones as you recall was just
ordered to pay something like a billion
dollars a billion dollars to the
families of the victims of the Sandy
Hook mass shooting and it bankrupted him
now of course Jones was wrong and what
he said about Sandy Hook he admits that
but as far as we know Howard Stern has
never apologized for his decision to
mock the victims of the Columbine school
shooting in fact Stern did not just mock
these victims
said that their Killers should have
raped them first before executing them
he actually said this on his show
listen
how's it going
all right
devour yeah oh man I lived like a mile
and a half in the school man I have a
couple friends that were there and I
talked to him yesterday what'd they say
they said that it was just a bunch of
chaos shooting and boy bunch of good
looking girls go to that school that guy
was right the guy who called him he was
a little too excited but he was like
there was like really good looking girls
running out of there with their hands
over their heads yeah I'd say the bomb
teams are still working did those kids
try to have sex with any of the
good-looking girls they didn't even do
that at least if you're gonna go kill
yourself and kill all the kids like why
wouldn't you have some sex
these guys were really against the
good-looking girls because the good
looking girls want to pay attention to
them I don't think the good looking
girls would be begging them to live and
they go you don't have to beg because
you're gonna be dead in a minute yeah
don't cry don't cry yes
so that's pretty much the most vile
thing a human being could possibly say
that's that's like the worst
now I personally give people a lot of
leeway for jokes quote unquote made
years ago in a different time when
people aren't as sensitive and edgy
humor wasn't as edgy back then it was a
different world it's a different culture
but this is Way Beyond the bounds of
what would have been considered remotely
acceptable even in the 90s
this is again perhaps the worst thing
I've ever heard anyone say ever
it's the kind of thing that that how
could that even come to your mind how
are you even thinking about that
he's not only joking about a school
shooting right after it happened this
was a day later
you have to understand something about
Columbine when it happened I mean this
was of course any school shooting is a
terrible tragedy very sad
um but at the time
you know this was for Columbine for
those who lived through it it's it was
it was like similar to 911 before 9 11
happened just the effect it had on the
country uh just the kind of shell shock
that most people are experiencing the
next day and for and for weeks after
and here he is a day later
telling quote unquote jokes
about how the kids who were just killed
should have been raped
lusting after the survivors of the
school shooting and saying the shooter
should have raped their victims
think about how much you use your phone
the scary part is that your phone
carrier collects data on whatever it is
you're doing they say it's they say that
it's so that they can better understand
your interest but really all they want
is to sell your activity to advertisers
stuff like the sites you visited and
what you've been up to online the more
they can get on you the larger their
paycheck becomes which is why I use
expressvpn expressvpn is an app that
prevents your phone carrier from being
able to see the sites you visit and sell
it to third parties uh to third parties
and all it takes is one half of a button
all of your network data gets encrypted
and rerouted through expressvpn secure
servers for ultimate privacy easy
effective no reason not to do it not
only does it Shield your web browsing
expressvpn protects all of your network
data so you can stay private even when
using your favorite apps whether you're
an iPhone Android or even a tablet user
expressvpn works on all of your devices
the best part is one subscription can be
used on up to five devices at the same
time when your phone carrier tracks you
that's a gross invasion of privacy you
can either keep letting them cash in on
you or you can visit expressvpn.com
expresvpn.com Walsh to get protected
expressvpn.com Welsh
keep in mind that he said all this
he said all this when he was a grown man
in his mid-40s
but Howard Stern has never been banned
from any social media platform for those
comments he wasn't ordered to pay a
billion dollars
uh to the to the how do you think the
the victim the the families the parents
of those children
must have felt hearing that
did he ever have to pay them a billion
dollars in restitution you need to pay
him a dime
that's because fortunately for stern he
mocked the Columbine victims prior to
this new era of wokeness where free
speech is illegal as long as it's
sufficiently uh you know offensive and
now just to cover his basis Stern has
completed his transition into the cult
of wokeness soon enough to protect
himself against cancellation
now they're not going to come after him
because he's on their team
which is part of the strategy for Howard
Stern of course this was not a
coincidence that he decided to to make
this transition into being fully woke
pro-trans Pro vaccine everything
complaining about Donald Trump I guess
every show I don't listen to a show at
all but that's what it seems like
now meanwhile Russell Brand is being
demonetized based on accusations alone
unlike Howard Stern Russell Brand never
publicly expressed his sexual attraction
to 13 year old girls uh he never said
that school shooting victims should have
been raped
um but he has expressed skepticism about
big Pharma and the war in Ukraine
and for that reason this week a culture
Committee in the UK Parliament sent
Rumble a letter requesting that they
demonetize Russell Brand quoting from
the letter quote I'm writing concerning
the serious allegations regarding
Russell Brand we would like to know
whether Rumble intends to join YouTube
in suspending Mr Brand's ability to earn
money on the platform
in the most passive aggressive fashion
imaginable the UK Parliament also sent
out a similar letter to tick tock quote
we'll be grateful if you could confirm
whether Mr brand is able to monetize his
Tick Tock posts including his videos
relating to the serious accusations
against him and what the platform is
doing to ensure the creators are not
able to use the platform to undermine
the welfare of victims of inappropriate
and potentially illegal Behavior
now let's take stock of what we're
seeing here this is the government of
the UK
effectively telling multiple social
media platforms to demonetize
one of the most influential commentators
on the planet solely on the basis of
unproven allegations
this is the government
moving to have Financial penalties
imposed on someone without any criminal
conviction at all
not just no criminal conviction no
criminal charge
has even been levied at this point
there's no plausible deniability here
they're being pretty much as explicit as
they can possibly be about it
before the Twitter files came out this
would have been dismissed as a wild
conspiracy theory
you weren't allowed to think that
governments were colluding with big Tech
to censor unapproved voices
but now the government is just coming
out and admitting that's exactly what
they're doing
this isn't just happening in the UK the
by the administration does it too
well unlike its competitor YouTube
Rumble emphatically rejected the request
from the UK government to their credit
but YouTube is the far bigger platform
and their decision to instantaneously
demonetize Russell Brand sets a very
worrying precedent
and also a totally incoherent and
inconsistent one
as Elijah Schaefer has pointed out cardi
B is currently fully monetized on
YouTube and that in spite of the fact
that she if you want to talk about what
things have people have done in their
past
she openly admits to drugging and
robbing men in her past it's on tape she
admits it watch
cardi B is responding to a whole lot of
backlash she is getting for an admission
that she made on an Instagram live video
three years ago now someone brought it
back up
the internet likes to do that sort of
thing and cardi was talking about her
days when she was working as a stripper
and she admitted that she would take
guys back to hotel rooms drug them and
Rob them here's what she said
[Music]
I mean you can't understand what the
hell she's saying but just to translate
for you yes she she openly admits and
brags about the fact that when she was a
stripper she would uh you know cozy up
to guys and she would get them back to
the apartment and then she would drug
them and then she would Rob them violent
felonies that she's bragging about
her history as a confessed date rapist
has not precluded her from major
corporate sponsorships or monetization
on YouTube
you know we call this a double standard
but double standard isn't really the
right term for this it's really one
standard
and the standard is if you're useful to
the left if you're on their team
you can essentially do whatever you want
you could say whatever you want you
could do whatever you want
that is the standard consistently
applied
and nobody can really deny that anymore
this is not an arbitrary application of
Shifting sets of Standards this again is
one standard leftists are immune that's
the rule that's the standard
now with that in mind
we might ask what's the appropriate
response
because pointing out hypocrisy is not
going to do anything
it's not accomplishing much
we've learned that much over the past
few years
what's needed is some courage we need
more of what Rumble is doing Rumble
knows that Russell Brand might actually
be guilty of what he's accused of doing
after all he was an admitted sex
addicted degenerate back when these
crimes supposedly occurred it certainly
is not outside the realm of possibility
that he did treat the women the way that
he's accused of treating them but the
leadership of Rumble understands that it
makes no sense to unperson Russell Brand
based on mere allegations
when we know for a fact that Brand's
critics are entirely motivated by
politics
they want to meet out punishments only
to the enemies of the regime while its
allies and lackeys are given exemptions
cow Towing to these people is not a
smart or sustainable strategy we just
can't do it
in fact all we can really do now
is just ignore everything that the
system says and assume for all intents
and purposes that everyone they demonize
is innocent
now
if we're being honest that's not always
going to be true sometimes we'll be
wrong and we'll end up defending people
who are guilty sometimes the system will
say every once in a while the system
will say something true
every once in a while maybe the system
villainizes someone who actually is a
villain
but the problem is that they lie so
often about so many things and they're
so blatantly driven by ideology and by
narrative
and are so wildly dishonest
and their motives are so evil
that we have we have to ignore them
completely at this point
by by defending and promoting the most
odious scumbags Among Us by embracing
ghouls like Howard Stern and cardi B
they've really left us no choice hey
YouTube thanks for listening to the show
if you'd like access to my full show
with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there